hello good evening if some of you would
like to come in and fill this area up
here we don't advertise that the gravel
is comfortable but we do advertise that
you can hear very well and you can see
very well my name is Alana hi I'm the
director of ps1 which is as you have
perhaps just discovered is not a real
school but a school for art and after
you get through with the program I hope
that you'll explore the school none of
you anticipated perhaps coming to school
tonight but indeed you have and we are
very very grateful to have you I'd like
to introduce Tony Guerrero who is the
guy over with the ponytail and if you
run into trouble he's the director of
operations and he's the one who can save
you our next introduction is brett
Lippmann who's the deputy director and
he's going to explain to you what will
happen tonight thank you very much for
coming Thank You Alana so it's really
terrific to see how many people have
come out to Queens on a Wednesday
evening and we're gonna try to get
things started right away I think that
we are all fortunate to live in New York
a city that really values art and
creative expression is essential public
resource here at ps1 we've really felt
for the past thirty years that there is
a social value in art and that young
artists should be directly involved in
the creative process it ps1 has been
really a meeting place for New Yorkers
and for the whole world for 30 years and
it's a very important institution in the
New York cultural firmament so to speak
that's why we're thrilled to host
tonight's engagement forum with
generation engage and when the speaking
program concludes I really encourage you
to walk through the building there are
about six or seven exhibitions that are
opened on the second floor and if it
doesn't start to rain we will open up
the James Turrell room which is a
beautiful room up on the third floor and
I encourage you to come back on June
25th if you have time we have a big pub
opening then and also on July 1st is our
first summer warmup
where they'll be DJ's in the courtyard
and also the young architects program
which you see behind us will be
completed so I just want to thank you
again and now if I can introduce Jason
Paige New York's the generation engaged
in New York City outreach coordinator
thank you thanks Brett thanks Alana
thanks for coming tonight my name is
Jason page on the New York City outreach
coordinator for a generation engage
how're you guys doing tonight
we're gonna try to get started here
because Alberto Alberta is that
hurricane Alberta is is coming our way
so we're gonna try to stave off the
hurricane and get started with Michael
Arad and Spike Lee a few years ago a
group of young people found a generation
engage on a couple key principles the
first principle is that young people do
not suffer from a lack of interest they
suffer from a lack of access this is
especially true for the 49% of young
Americans that do not have a college
education or living in rural and
inner-city communities and are
disconnected from the political process
you might have a college degree you
might not you might be black white
Latino Asian rich or poor young or old
but we are all here as members of
generation engages network because we
seek to form lines of communication
where they did not exist before the
second principle is that we believe
democracy is a dialogue not a monologue
those of you that have been to
generation engage forums before know
that this organization is devoted to
interactive dialogue about issues that
matter to us most however tonight is a
little bit more unique tonight is unique
in that we are definitely going to be
engaging in verbal debate but we're also
celebrating artistic expression and the
vital role that it plays in the civic
health of this city on that note I'd
like to introduce and thank someone here
tonight that is shown by example that by
investing in arts institutions
throughout the city it benefits every
single New Yorker so join me please in
thanking our special friend mr. Lewis
Coleman
one thing I want to point out is the
program that you have is wrapped around
today's issue of the Metro New York
Metro New York is a strategic partner of
generation engaged and what they've done
is they've given us a program wrap
around their daily newspaper so if you
look just inside you'll see a program
and a description of the artists that
are speaking tonight a brief synopsis of
what's going to happen over the course
of the evening and if you go to the
second to last page you'll see a couple
bits of information that you might find
useful in the bottom corner is a
selection of our strategic partners that
helped us with this event tonight
there's a description of the
relationship between Metro New York and
generation engage there's a piece about
ps1 you can find a little bit more
information about ps1 and some
interesting facts that the Alliance for
the Arts has provided for us about arts
spending in New York City if you look at
the back there are photographs of
Michael a-rod's design of the World
Trade Center Memorial and you might want
to reference these photographs as he's
speaking because you'll get a good idea
of his design that he has planned for
for downtown I'd like to recognize a
couple elected officials that that are
here tonight
the first is Josh nacho it's from
councilmember Dominick recce his office
he believe he's here tonight secondly is
councilmember Helen Foster and thirdly
Eric Joya councilmember Eric Joya who's
26 district we are we are in tonight
thank you very very much for having us
and now without further ado I'd like to
introduce our keynote speakers for
tonight mr. Spike Lee and mr. Michael
Arad hello everyone how you doing don't
get the Queens that much seven for
LaGuardia or occasionally Mets game
they're doing good now I'm glad glad to
be and glad to see the young faces here
many of you want to pursue a career in
the arts and I think there's no better
time than in the president I did not
know I want to be a filmmaker until I
was a sophomore in college
excuse me at the end of my sophomore
year so don't feel too bad you still not
decided what you want to do well I think
that you have to be very serious now
instead of lollygagging and thinking
about what is your going to do with the
rest of your life we're at a very
critical time in this country and for
your generation twice as many people
graduated in college than when I went I
finished Morehouse College way back in
1979 so there's twice as many people
going for the jobs that that you might
want to get again it's very important to
find out what does you want to do and
also I like to say
what is it that you love not what's
gonna make me the most money what is it
that you love big difference big
difference I was very fortunate because
when people say when I decide wanna be a
filmmaker I didn't decide film chose me
there's so many things are happening my
life this past 20 years I can look back
and reflection and see that it was not a
mistake it was not a humbug it wasn't a
humble everything I've done up to that
point directed me to being a filmmaker
and it's what I love it's not I did not
go into film because I wanted to make a
lot of money and be in front of the
camera or all the other stuff it's what
I love and by filming and I'm not just
talking about the feature films I do
commercials I do music videos short
films and documentaries to me all that
comes under the heading of filmmaking
and another important thing I like the
stress in this short address I was very
fortunate that my parents did not crush
my dream when I said I want to be a
filmmaker and my humble opinion parents
kill more dreams than anybody and they
don't do it on purpose
parents don't do it on purpose every
parent wants more for their sons and
daughter than what they had but in their
wisdom they think that they can dictate
to you what's gonna be the best route
and so often when children excuse me
when young adults decide to make a move
that's in the arts they get shut down by
their parents
you can't make no money doing that you
just me driving a cab you're gonna be a
waitress and a lot and we and we put a
lot of stock of what our parents tell us
and then when they put that parental
guilt on us we succumb end up living our
life but what they want us to do
consequently you end up a miserable
human being so do what you want to do
that is not an act of not loving your
parents it's your life so many of my
classmates I went to school with succumb
to print the pressure why many of them
were the first members or their family
ever go to college a lot of them their
parents and make great sacrifices work
two or three jobs mortgage the house and
great again great sacrifice were meant
to descending through college instead of
when it kind when when the parents asked
them that day there always comes that
day so were you gonna major in the
parents think well business I'm going to
loss pre-law med but some would say well
I want me a poet I want to be a writer I
want to be a dancer um me and your
mother did not work our fingers to the
bone if you want to do that then get the
do you not the work your way through
college and so they can't do that they
succumb once again and many years later
they're miserable because they chose the
path which is not in their heart so real
that's the most important thing I tell
you that I can i real I can convey to
you today find out what it is that you
want to do you do not believe me you do
not want to be in position 5 10 15 years
from now where every morning you're
dragging you ass out of bed going to a
job do you hate you don't want to be
there they don't want you there either
but you go because you have bills your
kids have to eat
they got have clothes jazz dishes they
have a slang for a job they caught a
slave you don't want to be musician in
the future going to a job that you hate
you want to be in position where you're
eager to wake up every morning because
you love what you're doing you would do
this job free you love it so much
the key is find out what that is and I'm
going to answer questions and answers
thank you very much next Thank You mr.
Lee
for those words of wisdom next I'd like
to introduce the designer of the World
Trade Center Memorial mr. Michael Arad
first I should thank Spike Lee my
parents wanted me to be a lawyer and I
didn't get into law school it worked out
yeah ah okay
when Justin asked me to come and speak
here tonight he talked about artistic
expression and civic engagement which I
thought was a way of saying art and
politics and I was very nervous about
the idea of speaking about art in
politics because I think they're very
often when those two come together it
could be you know either propaganda or a
caricature you know and it sort of
between those two poles and sometimes
it's both but I thought about the phrase
civic engagement and it sounds a lot
better than politics and I thought what
can I do with that and I think that on
some level the reason that I I'm
involved in this project is because of
this idea of civic engagement and and it
came from a from a place that it wasn't
civic engagement because I sort of set
out I want to be engaged it was in
response to what happened here on
September 11th and before that you know
living in New York was it's a very easy
City to sort of be in but not be of you
can sort of observe everything and keep
a nice cool distance from it and I
didn't have that option after September
11th I saw what happened firsthand and
and seeing those events really and
seeing the reaction of New Yorkers to
those events meant so much to me and it
really made me feel connected it made me
feel like there's a community here that
I didn't really feel part of before that
and I remember going to Washington
Square Park a few nights after September
11th and standing there around that
fountain in the middle of the park at
about 2:00 in the morning and I came
there by myself and there were probably
a dozen people standing around that foul
and I felt this strong sense of
community that we were there together we
didn't say anything no words were spoken
people weren't holding hands but you
felt that you weren't alone when you
were there with other people and that
was my feeling about New York or at
least how it was four years ago and it
was out of that sense of community not
because I wanted to to be engaged
because I didn't really feel I had any
sense but to be engaged that I started
thinking about a memorial and this
process began for me about four years
ago and I had this image in my mind if
these two voids in the Hudson River that
water just sort of falling into them and
they would never fill up and you can see
that on the back of the program it said
image on the top of the page and I just
imagined the these two empty vessels
water flowing into them continuously and
never and never filling you up and for
me there were there were way of
conveying the sense of absence and loss
which I felt at the time and about a
year later and actually this image was
so so forcefully stuck in my head that I
felt the need to actually build this
little model which you see photograph
there and I could imagine the reflection
of the City and the Hudson River and
seeing the these two voices and you know
markers of of absence about a year later
they announced the competition for the
design of the memorial and I tried to
see if there's any way I could take that
idea if those two hordes and bring it to
the site which would be very different
instead of seeing them in the distance
you would actually be standing right
there on the site of where the towers
once stood and I came up with this idea
of this flat plane were these two
enormous pools which would be cut into
it and he would come down below ground
to these galleries which would surround
the pools and to me the this space is so
important because what I wanted to do is
capture what I felt here in New York
after September 11th to create a place
where people could come together could
face the names
of all these people who died here and
not feel alone as they were doing it but
feel that they were part of something
greater and and that's what I'm trying
to do right now with the memorial is to
see that realized and I think I'll stop
there if you have any questions I'll be
happy to take them
thank you mr. rod at this time we're
gonna take questions from you all
so Justin raise your hand everybody sees
Justin over here we're gonna have people
line up over here so that we can get a
queue and then we can ask your questions
to mr. Lee and mr. rod and we'll go as
long as the clear skies will allow us
and then we'll have a chance to go
inside and experience the galleries so
who's first
yeah
good
all right first of all I want to say
it's an honor to be here like both for
you Spike Lee I've seen all the movies
and everything like that I'm a big fan
and I think it's crazy what you're doing
with the the memorial and I'm like first
of all I'm from the Whitney Museum I'm
an intern at the wind museum my name is
Raphael yeah and I'm gonna ask um my
questions for Spike Lee I'm gonna act
some like as a musician in that artist
I've always wondered that like you have
a sacrifice like some individual flair
or your style like if you want to play
in order to be successful or like to
make it so like um has that ever
happened to you like have you ever had
to inhibit yourself artistically so I'm
a piece like the powers-that-be
not really I think that film is a much
different art form did say someone who's
a painter or a writer films cost can
cost a lot of money
and the studios that give you the money
want to have a say so I've been very
fortunate that I've had a final cut in
my film so it's in my contract that I
had the final say but the same time you
just can't Bogart and say we're doing
what the [ __ ] I want to do and that's it
you know it has to be a dialogue and
some things you can scene on and the
other thing is like perfect example do
the right thing and do the right thing I
was originally set up another studio but
they don't like the way it ended and
they wanted Mookie and sow Mookie yeah
as Rosie Perez how's our pronunciation
Mookie the studio wanted a Mookie and
Sal the shake hands hug kiss and sing we
the world into the movie and we weren't
doing that
so we ended up making it somewhere else
all right all right thank you thank you
good evening my name is kianga Ellis I'm
president of an organization called a
veil art and we develop programs to
interest professionals and financially
supporting the arts we're working with
young law firm summer associates this
summer and my questions for mr. Arad one
of the ways that we think we can get
professionals interested in providing
support for the Arts is to demonstrate
the relationship that art has in our
lives and particularly with your work as
an architect I wondered if you could
give us some advice as to how we can
demonstrate this role this greater role
that art has in our lives and help
inspire them to want to support artists
that's an easy question I think that he
can bring somebody to the water but he
can't make them drink and if people
don't feel that engagement is critical
to them it's gonna be very hard to get
them engaged and I think engagement is
critical if you don't have a voice in
this process you're not going to be
heard and I'm in a very different
process right now in fact a process
where everybody has a voice in the
process and so many different parties
bring their input to it and I think
that's critically important it makes my
life very difficult and but if people
weren't engaged in the process then the
outcome would have no meaning to them
and I think simply conveying to people
that the city that we live in is not
just a product of chance it's a product
of thousands of decisions that affect us
all and if you don't participate in that
process you're just you know you're just
visiting
okay
my name is hey mom set I'm also an
intern at the Whitney and my question is
for mr. Spike Lee I know that as we're
talking about doing the right thing
before that's the most critically
acclaimed film in terms of you know what
Hollywood is concerned he was up for
Oscar nomination but I wanted to ask you
do you feel that you personally think it
was your best film in terms of conveying
a strong message to the people and do
you think of that message that you tried
to convey is still relevant 16 to 17
years from when you first made it oh yes
I think that the stuff we dealt with the
do the right thing is very prominent
today you heard of fat Nick Manucci
whatever his name is
that's funny he says I wasn't using an
n-word I heard on the rap records so Mis
been like the guy had a baseball bat you
know we had a baseball bat do the right
thing - so what was it like come on I
was not the use of the n-word beating
somebody over the head with a baseball
bat that's not a term of endearment we
crack some mine skull at the Louisville
Slugger so I wasn't surprised we took
place in Howard Beach either where
really it was it that's where I got the
impetus for do the right thing three
african-american men car had a flat they
went into pizzeria in Howard Beach the
call triple-a run out of the pizza
raided by gang at bat wielding
italian-american used one of the guys
ran on the BQE who to hit by a car that
was really one of the the things that
triggered me to write do the right thing
so the stuff we dealt with in that film
is still with us
today and I'm not proud of it I wish
that uh that race was not issued not
just in New York City but in in where we
live in in fact the new film I'm not not
inside man but the new film I'm working
on is a documentary on Hurricane Katrina
as effect on New Orleans it's called
when the levees broke as for HBO was
four hours long and that's a definite
example of how race and class played a
bit of a big effect you know on on New
Orleans my name is Tiana Watson and I'm
with the Harlem Children's Zone Youth
Leadership Program and my question is
for mr. right um you said that you
witnessed the attack on 9/11 firsthand I
wanted to know how you combine jovi the
actions with the reactions and millions
of other people who also witnessed it
instead of creating a memorial
yeah it was at home that morning my wife
was actually at work downtown and I saw
the the second plane as it crashed into
the towers and then I tried to find her
and I went downtown and I was on Fulton
Street when the first tower came falling
down and you know I think it is because
if that sort of immediate and direct
connection to it that I've felt the need
to do something and it came from
someplace it was very personal and
emotional but at the moment that a
design is selected and it goes into a
public process you have to find a way to
actually bring everyone else into it
this can't be it's not my memorial I
don't have a single message which has
any more value than anybody else's
reaction to it and so as you approach
something like this you have to find a
way to to not impose a single voice on
the design you can't this is not this is
public it's not owned by me I'm just
part of the process that can make it
happen hopefully but if I didn't have a
personal reaction to it if I didn't have
something to draw on to sort of guide me
throughout these decisions then I
wouldn't be able to do the project
either because you can't open it up to
the point where you have no say in the
project anymore and it's finding that
balance that's incredibly difficult I've
never done a project like this before I
know and I'm just kind of finding my way
through it as I go through it
good afternoon my name is Rachel
Stockdale I'm an intern at the beast
Brooklyn Children's Museum and my
question my question is for both of you
guys mr. rod and mr. Lee I wanted to
know what is the responsibility of an
artist to his or her community very good
question what the responsibilities of an
artist to his or his or her community I
think that's that's a very personal
individual question that really you
can't dictate to an artists with the
responsibility is there are some artists
who feel and you might say rightfully so
that they were only responsibilities to
their art that they don't own adapted to
the community from which they came from
and all the artists seen as readings for
art to reflect your community so that
really depends on the individual I think
that but for me personally I think that
I do have a a great responsibility I
understand where I come from where I
live and just growing up here in New
York City
most of my films have taken place here
and it's not something I try to run away
from the community at the same time if
you take that too far it can become a
burden because you really can't let
community dictate your art so it's it
could be you could put yourself on a
trick bag if you don't really navigate
you know either way I sort of mentioned
it earlier that I felt a need to be part
of the community when I a few years ago
but you know my son I've always thought
if myself to some degree as an outsider
and you know I'm from Israel but as I
grew up I grew up
Mexico and in England and the states in
Israel and that sort of constant moving
around and give me a sense if you know
shallow roots so to speak and and in
many ways what I considered my community
would be you know friends from school
friends from work family but in this
constant shuffle of moving all the time
it's very easy to also lose touch with
that and feel that you know you don't
need a community you've got yourself and
I think when what astonished me about
what happened in New York a few years
ago I mean to the point where I actually
went out and bought a flag and put it
outside my apartment which is something
I never would have thought I could have
done two days before that was the way
that people came together and we were
just talking about community and it can
be a terrible thing I mean some
definitions of community are exclusive
and what I saw in New York after 9/11
was actually people coming together and
you know perhaps it was short-lived
maybe it was just for a year or two but
I think there parts of that which are
always here and we got to hold on to
those parts hello my name is Charles
Lawrence and I'm from the Harlem
Children's Zone program my question is
directed to Spike Lee and I want to know
what other black youth needs to know in
order to pursue their dream of
filmmaking in Hollywood repeat the
question please
what does the black youth need to know
in order to pursue their dream of
filmmaking in Hollywood well I think
that they're more African I mean is
documented they're more African
Americans working in front of him behind
the camera never before not as many
african-american women direct men very
few but the opportunities are there
the hurdle is that there's still it's
hard to get outside the stereotypes that
are set up and the formal lake films the
ghettos which films for the
african-american moviegoers are locked
into so it's still a struggle but as
much better than it was if you look at
the people before me Mela Van Peebles
Gordon Parks the recent recently passed
along with Ossie Davis and the
grandfather African American cinema
asked him to show so I think that if
Oscar Micheaux looked at where we were
today he would be amazed that we made
the strides that we've done but there's
still a lot a lot of work more to go
good evening my name is Carl and I'm
from the flushing wat CA and my question
is to both mr. Lee and mr. Lou rod what
percentage of thoughts or ideas do you
put in to a positive effect to youth
such as your next movie or the number of
companies that give up opportunities for
high school students to intern or work
at the New World Trade Center I'm very
involved with the youth my mother was a
teacher my grandma was a teacher and I'm
a teacher I'm have been I've been a
professor I'm a professor NYU I've been
there the last nine years
I'm also artistic director to film
school so it's very important for me to
teach and have various scholarships you
know at NYU for needy and talented
students
and so I just I just like I like to
teach and I think that I'm a firm
believer in education I'm a product of
you know a great predominately
african-american school or Morehouse
College in Atlanta Georgia and my father
went to Morehouse my grandfather went to
Morehouse my mother and grandmother than
with the Spelman was across the street
some third generation you know you don't
have that many you know
african-americans who say that their
generation you know college educated got
my mass and Fine Arts from NYU so I
think some education something real
needs to be stressed today particularly
amongst youth of color where the many
messages are getting it from from the
music from hip-hop not all of hip-hop
but it's been documented many many young
people of color fail classes on purpose
because if you get aids
if you speak grammatically correct if
you could say one sentence about one
word being profane if you do those
things you're off the size you're called
a white boy a white girl a sellout if
you're hanging on the corner drinking a
40 smoking a blunt got your pants
drooping below your ass holding your
nuts then you're down from the hood and
you keep it real so this is the exact
opposite of who I think who we are as a
people I don't want to sound like I'm
preaching but this is the truth there
was a time when if you're
african-american it was a it was against
the law for your ancestors who were
slaves to learn how to read and write it
was against the law
so how is it that our ancestor the
risked life and limb because if you got
caught reading or writing or teaching
someone you got whipped lynched or hung
and if math was having a bad day you
might get all three but despite that our
ancestors knew education would be a key
and here we are fast forward to 2006 and
if you're educated you act and white
that shit's crazy that's insane
so are you have to understand this that
they can't succumb to peer pressure I
don't care how much we look cool you're
gonna get how much ribbon you get from
your friends gonna call you Corning and
whack and all other stuff do not devalue
education I don't care what the videos
what I don't care what you see in the
videos what 50 cents is saying don't
don't go for okey doke that's an easy
act to follow
if anybody's worried about getting A's
they should take a class with me they
won't now I actually taught for the
first time this year which was really
challenging experience I was teaching at
the new school I hope I have so fine
students here and it was a really
challenging experience it's a really
difficult thing to do to actually teach
and you have to find the time to do it
because it doesn't pay what it should
and I'd like to acknowledge Amanda Sachs
who's sitting over there for teaching
with me this last semester I had 12
students and I'm happy to report that
three of them are now working for me so
I could have been too bad because and
it's things like that I think it's
important for us to to not just feed our
lives professionally but also to take
time oh there are two of my students
right there they were hiding so they can
tell you later more about the new school
in the program there but I enjoyed
teaching despite the challenges of it
my name is Samantha Lawrence and I'm an
intern at the Brooklyn Children's Museum
and this question is directed to Spike
Lee I'm going to know for a future film
maker how did you overcome some of the
obstacles that came your way and what
like how did you deal with people
telling they telling you that you
wouldn't make it and like you should
take get a new career path something
like that what yeah I think I answered
maybe a little part of that question
before when I when I said that my
parents supported me 100% I think
there's also very important for people
when you are trying to strive we are
trying to go upward you have to cut
those negative people loose those people
who are gonna try to drag you back and
say you can't do this you can't do that
that stuff is like a cancer you might
not think has effect the new what if
somebody constantly keeps telling you
you can't do something you are gonna
start believing that so you just have to
surround yourself with positive people
who want to move forward want to be
progressive and if your friends aren't
doing that they got to go in my opinion
hello my name is Maggie Searles
and I'm from the Harlem Children's Zone
learn to earn program my question is
directed to Spike Lee all of your movies
have a certain message to tell people
was their incident or situation in your
life which made you feel making movies
was a way how to make a difference was
the way how you can make a difference in
life good question has always been this
debate how much art can't influence the
public and it's debatable I'll give an
example when I saw Michael Moore's film
Fahrenheit 9/11 I said I would have bet
the house that no way that Bush is
getting elected with it with the money
that film made as many people saw that
film I said there's no way with just the
evidence of the man's and confidence and
how he robbed the election anyway the
first time I just I just felt that the
American public have this information be
able to with their intelligible to make
the decision they get this guy out of
here and now I mean it's really great
filmmaking by Michael Moore and you know
who won so there's always gonna be
debate how much concrete effect does a
film or excuse not a film this art have
on society you know it really depends I
won I could give you an example Earl
Errol Morris made this film called The
Thin Blue Line a documentary and because
of this film
I forgot the guy's name I started from a
long time ago someone who's on death row
got off death row specifically because
of this film so that's an example I can
cite in recent memory where something
was concrete
but uh I think art can shape and
influence how people think as far as
something concrete you know it really
depends on the situation
I think hello my name is Joan and
Everett um I go to high school or in
design my question is for both of you I
was wondering what methods would you
suggest our society use to help get the
youth more active or more involved in
arts community
I'd say just go out there and I mean the
city is this huge work of art in Central
Park the museum's and I don't want to
sound too boosters about it but it's all
there if we don't you know you you
should take advantage of it but I really
don't have this or if a really deep
message about it if you should it if art
doesn't touch you and it's not going to
but if it does it's it's all here and
and use it when I went to the schools I
went to PS 29 in Cobble Hill I went to
PS 7 PS 8 due to high school 294 I went
to John Dewey high school Coney Island
and I'm 49 years old and in public
school when I was going to public school
you had art you have in 3rd to 4th grade
you had to take violin lessons whether
you want and not you had to take art
lessons and all over the country this
president ministration has cut art out
of the curriculum art and music so I
think that's something that we have to
do whatever we can to restore art music
back to the curriculum
across these United States of America I
mean whether you're gonna be me in this
new musician or not you should at least
be given the chance this I mean
everything is about exposure if you're
not exposed to these things how you know
if you're able to do it or not you might
have a a great gift but if you're not
exposed to that so I think that we had
to restore again I know my Ratanak done
did or restore art you know they cut Jim
out some schools don't even have a gym I
don't you know we have enough you know I
know how many billions we spend in Iraq
but we cut our now and all his other
stuff so it was just crazy now
my name is Matthew and from Brooklyn
this question is for both of you hello
Matthew
is that better I'm from Brooklyn and I'm
gonna ask both y'all question I look at
art and politics as being similar and
that each one is a way that people in
the public communicate with each other
public kind of communicates with itself
through artists politicians and over
time in America politics got good at
being interactive it's kind of what the
country is based on it was different
from other countries and art has become
a lot more interactive recently people
on the internet and even people playing
video games it kinda seemed to a March
side-by-side this way do you see
crossover and either techniques or even
if it's becoming indistinguishable in
some way indistinguishable with art and
politics
we ain't hear you hello yeah the way
they communicate with the public and the
public communicates with itself through
artists and politicians it's been kind
of different but now now maybe from the
points where you said it might be I
think art and politics have always been
intertwined you know there's always this
thing I I heard that when artists
decides to leave art out of his work
that's a excuse me artists decide to
leave politics out of his art that's a
political decision there so it really
again it really depends on artists there
are some artists who feel that politics
should not be a part of their art of
this think that it should so it's still
like it really comes down to individual
choice that's really only way I can
answer that
that's it my name is Eugene Burrell I'm
with the Harlem Children's Zone Youth
Leadership Program and on my question is
directed to Spike Lee I'm a creative
person in your creative person and I
believe in a phrase by any means
necessary
so what advice would you give me as an
african-american in my college career
what grade you in
I'm going to college in the fall where
you going to school nursing
that's where Charles Oakley went and Ben
Wallace you don't play basketball do you
know football
do you have a scholarship there are you
gonna play football yes I think that you
know is so-so especially for the
brothers when they go to college and
especially to athletes you know they
don't hit the books a lot don't hit the
books seriously and not because their
sole focus on making the league whether
it be an NBA or NFL not everybody's
playing pro ball so I urge you to do the
best you can on the gridiron but I'll
equally study and come out with the
degree just in case you don't make it to
NFL what position you play you're kind
of small for a defensive tackle brother
so right you better hit those books
you weighed 215 pounds you know what
defensive tackles weigh in NFL there we
are with 300 pounds without steroids
just add not a different note I didn't
discover architecture until my last year
in college so go into this with an open
mind I mean going to this not knowing
what you're going to come out with it's
find what you want to do don't you know
you talk about parents earlier like my
first semester in school I took a stage
management class astronomy class and
something else my parents are freaking
out
what are we sending you to school for
and there's always that pressure to to
figure out what you're gonna do with the
rest of your life right now but don't
feel don't let that pressure lock out
the possibility of things something else
tomorrow hello my name is Tamar and I'm
a community organizer and downtown
Brooklyn Fort Greene and faragut Mike my
question is Potenza a lot of the urban
gentrification that's happening
specifically in low-income and community
of color and I wanted to know Fort
Greene and Farragut it was just a
historical black community I wanted to
know what your thoughts are what are you
doing to speak the light and bring truth
to this another war at home on
low-income community I think Katrina is
no different than what's going on in New
York City and Chicago and LA and across
the nation well I agree the most you
said chicag was not eighty percent
eighty percent of Chicago was not under
water eighty percent New York City was
not under water so that analogy is not
really
renina urban gentrification where
developers and private business take
over community ownership where services
that I needed such as drugstore
affordable laundromat affordable
supermarket are no longer in the control
of the community but in the private
market how do what work are you doing or
how do you suggest bringing light to it
through the odds well which as of yet
I've not done a film about
gentrification I don't know that's a
movie I grew up before Green so it's an
iMovie out is amazing office is still
there I never thought I'd live to see
the day where you have white linen
tables and sidewalk cafes on Myrtle
Avenue no less Myrtle Avenue and when
you have white homesteaders in bed-stuy
I'm thinking about Harlem I mean they're
you know people New York City is
becoming people can't live here anymore
whether you're either have to be a
millionaire or you can't afford to live
here and that and that has nothing to do
with race because the Bohemian is did
used to live in the Lower East Side they
had to move out they went no they moved
to Williamsburg and now I can't afford
Williamsburg so that comes a point where
where people gonna live and I think that
you know this is something we have to
express with the powers that be if you
look at the Mayor Bloomberg you know is
he in cahoots with the real estate
people you know it's questionable but
you should be able to I think that's one
of the keys I think that for for the
future New York see we have to have
affordable housing we have to have jobs
and also we have to have
a great education system again I'm a
product of a New York City public
education system but it's different now
then I went to school and I think there
was some figures that came out the half
of african-american males here in New
York City drop out before they reached
high school and that's criminal and so
anybody has any money unless you get
your kids into Stuyvesant science or
Brooklyn Tech or you might have
LaGuardia if your art or art design you
just send your kids to private school so
this is this is a big dilemma but I
don't have the answer for that at all
but I'm glad you brought that question
up because it is
I'm glad you stepped in the mic because
that is a big issue and you see it
firsthand in Fort Greene thank you I'd
like to thank the people that ask
questions unfortunate we're gonna have
to cut it off right here give yourselves
that give yourselves a round of applause
I apologize to those of you that were
waiting to ask questions but I want to
give everyone an opportunity to explore
the exhibits that are inside ps1 but I
want to remind everybody that the
conversation doesn't stop here it
continues I want to thank everybody for
coming and I would like to invite you to
go to the website which is posted behind
me WWE generation gays org
we've posted a question specific to this
event on our blog that I'd love for each
one of you to respond to I'd also like
to thank our engagement partners in this
event
ps1 Metro New York and please go forth
enjoy the exhibits inside ps1 happy
Juneteenth and stay engaged thank you